No one goes to Hank's for his spreadsheets. They go for a darn good pizza. Lately, though, the shop's been quiet. So Hank decides to bring back the $1 slice. He asks Copilot in Microsoft Excel to look at his sales and costs to help him see if he can afford it. Co-pilot shows Hank where the money's going and which little extras make the dollar slice work.
没有人是为了汉克的电子表格而去的，他们是为了那里的美味披萨。不过最近，店里却有些冷清。于是，汉克决定推出1美元的披萨切片。他请微软Excel中的Copilot查看他的销售额和成本，以帮他看看自己是否负担得起。Copilot向汉克展示了资金的去向，以及哪些小点缀能让1美元披萨的促销顺利进行。
Now, Hank has a line out the door. Hank makes the pizza. Co-Pilot handles the spreadsheets. Learn more at M365Copilot.com slash work. Speaking of psychology is taking a summer break, so we're rerunning some of our favorite episodes from the past. In 2022, I talked to Yale University Psychology Professor Paul Bloom about why people like to do scary and difficult things from watching horror movies to running marathons and the connection between pleasure and pain. I hope you enjoy this episode from the archives. We'll be back with new episodes in two weeks.
现在，汉克的店门前排起了长队。汉克负责做披萨，Copilot负责处理电子表格。访问M365Copilot.com slash work了解更多信息。说回心理学栏目正在放暑假，因此我们正在重播过去的一些热门单集。2022年，我采访了耶鲁大学心理学教授保罗·布鲁姆，探讨了人们为什么喜欢做惊悚和困难的事情，从看恐怖电影到跑马拉松，以及快乐与痛苦之间的联系。希望大家喜欢这期历史音频。两周后我们将携新节目回归。
What Makes for a Good Life? You might think that the best life would be one of unadulterated happiness, where moments of pain and suffering never intrude on your comfort and joy. But why then do people often seek out hardship? Many of us like to watch scary movies or listen to songs that make us cry. We choose to run marathons and to raise children, even though both of those pursuits inevitably come with struggle and pain. Why do we do these things?
什么造就了美好生活？你可能会认为，最好的生活应该是纯粹的快乐，在那种生活里，痛苦和苦难的时刻绝不会侵扰你的舒适与喜悦。但为什么人们又常常去寻求艰难困苦呢？我们中的很多人喜欢看恐怖电影或听让人流泪的歌。我们选择跑马拉松、抚养孩子，尽管这两项追求都不可避免地伴随着挣扎与痛苦。我们为什么要这样做？
What do we get out of the pain and suffering that we choose to experience? What does it add to our lives? And what about pain that we don't choose? Do illness, poverty, or the death of a loved one add meaning to our lives? Does unchosen suffering make us better, stronger, or more moral? Or is it always a bad thing? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life.
我们从选择经历的痛苦和苦难中得到了什么？它给我们的生活增添了什么？那些我们没有选择的痛苦呢？疾病、贫困或至亲的离世会给我们的生活增添意义吗？未经选择的苦难能让我们变得更好、更坚强或更有道德吗？还是说它永远都是一件坏事？欢迎收听《说心理学》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。
I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Paul Bloom, a professor of science. a professor of psychology at the University of Toronto, and the Brooks and Suzanne Reagan Professor Emeritus of Psychology at Yale University. His most recent book is The Sweet Spot, The Pleasures of Suffering and the Search for Meaning. More broadly, he studies how children and adults make sense of the world with a special focus on pleasure, morality, religion, fiction, and art. He is co-editor of the journal Behavioral and Brain Sciences, and, in addition to scientific publications,
我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是保罗·布鲁姆博士，他是科学教授，多伦多大学心理学教授，以及耶鲁大学心理学布鲁克斯和苏珊·里根名誉教授。他最近出版的一本著作是《甜蜜点：痛苦的快乐与意义的寻觅》。更广泛地说，他研究儿童和成人是如何理解世界的，尤其关注快乐、道德、宗教、小说和艺术。他是《行为与大脑科学》杂志的共同主编，除了科学出版物之外，
he writes for popular outlets, including the New York Times, the Atlantic, and the New Yorker. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Bloom. Thank you for having me, Kim, and that was a wonderful introduction. Great. Well, we're going to be talking about a lot of those. So let's start first by talking about what you mean by suffering. That's a pretty strong word. And some people might think that an experience must be really terrible in order to be categorized as suffering. But you take a wider view.
他还为《纽约时报》、《大西洋月刊》和《纽约客》等大众媒体撰稿。非常感谢今天能作客我们的节目，布鲁姆博士。谢谢你邀请我，金，这段介绍真是太棒了。太好了。那么，我们将讨论其中许多内容。让我们首先来谈谈你所说的“痛苦”是什么意思。这是一个相当强烈的词。有些人可能会认为，一种经历必须真的很糟糕，才能被归类为痛苦。但你持有一种更广阔的视角。
So what's your definition? Yeah, I think it's important. It's a good question. It's important for us to be clear what we're talking about. Some people only use suffering to refer to real heavy duty experiences. And I'm very interested in those. I'm very interested in extremes of pain or anguish. But the puzzle I sort of set myself to solving is why we pursue suffering in a broader sense. So it includes the pain you might experience you're running a marathon, a BDSM, it includes effort, including severe effort, but also milder stuff. Why do we like? you know, chicken vindaloo or spicy foods. Why do we like the effort of a crossword puzzle? And so if somebody says, oh, those aren't, that's not suffering in my heavy duty sense. I totally agree. I'm using suffering in a broader sense. So we're a little bit limited then by our language, right? I mean, English doesn't have many nuances for those types of strains that we place on ourselves.
那么你的定义是什么？是的，我认为这很重要。这是一个好问题。对我们来说，明确我们在谈论什么很重要。有些人只用“痛苦”来指代真正沉重的经历。我对这些很感兴趣。我对极端的痛苦或悲痛非常感兴趣。但我为自己设定的难题是，为什么我们在更广泛的意义上追求痛苦。所以这包括你跑马拉松时可能经历的痛苦、BDSM，它包括努力，包括极大的努力，但也包括一些较轻微的东西。我们为什么喜欢呢？你知道，比如鸡肉温达卢或辛辣食物。为什么我们喜欢解填字游戏的这种费劲的过程？因此，如果有人说，哦，那些不是，在我的沉重意义上那不是痛苦。我完全同意。我是在更广阔的意义上使用“痛苦”这个词的。因此，我们在语言上确实受到了一点限制，对吧？我的意思是，英语对于我们施加在自己身上的那些压力，并没有太多的细微差别。
That's right. I, you know, I was trying to think of another single word, you know, bad experiences as close as I could come to it. But I'm kind of another way. of putting it is, if we don't want to use the word suffering at all, I'm interested in why we voluntarily expose ourselves to experiences that under normal circumstances we would avoid. So typically pain, effort, struggle, emotional anguish are bad. We want to avoid them. The puzzle I'm interested in is why do we sometimes seek them up? Well, why do you believe then that some pain and suffering are necessary in life? When I started writing this book, I had one answer in mind, which was I was very interested in role of pain and suffering as a source of pleasure.
没错。你知道，我一直在试图想出另一个单独的词，你知道，差不多就是“糟糕的经历”。但我换了一种表达方式。换句话说，如果我们完全不想用“痛苦”这个词，我感兴趣的是，为什么我们自愿让自己暴露在这样一种经历中——在正常情况下我们会避开它们。所以通常痛苦、努力、挣扎、情感上的痛苦都是不好的。我们想要避开它们。我感兴趣的谜题是，为什么我们有时会主动寻找它们？那么，在你看来，为什么有些痛苦和苦难在生活中是必要的呢？当我开始写这本书时，我心里只有一个答案，那就是我非常对痛苦和苦难作为快乐之源的作用感兴趣。
You know, why do we get a kick out of it? Why do we get a kick out of, you know, spicy foods and BDSM and all sorts of things, scary movies? But as I began to write the book and read and talk to people and think about this, I made an argument that there's something else going on. I think something deeper, which is we're not only interested in pleasure. And some of the voluntary pain and suffering a struggle we pick up, isn't service of other goals like morality or like having a meaningful life, having a life of transcendent value. So let's dig into the connection then between suffering and pleasure just a little bit more.
你知道，为什么我们从中获得乐趣？为什么我们从吃辣、BDSM、各种事情、恐怖电影中获得乐趣？但当我开始写这本书，阅读、与人交谈并思考这个问题时，我提出了一个论点，即还有其他事情正在发生。我认为有更深层次的东西，那就是我们不仅对快乐感兴趣。我们所承担的一些自愿的痛苦、苦难和挣扎，其实是为了服务于其他目标，比如道德，或者拥有一个有意义的生活，拥有一个具有超越价值的生活。因此，让我们再深入探讨一下痛苦和快乐之间的联系。
It touches on several things that I mentioned in the intro, like watching horror movies, listening to sad songs on a more extreme. And you've talked about BDSM. I just want to tell some of our vanilla listeners that that refers to bondage, dominance, submission, sadomasochism, sexual. practices, which you talk about at length in the book, you delve into several possible explanations for why so many of us seem to actually enjoy doing the things that bring us, either physical or emotional pain. So what are the fundamental reasons for that in your view?
它触及了我在引言中提到的一些事情，比如看恐怖电影、听悲伤的歌，更极端一点的。你还谈到了BDSM。我只想对我们那些比较传统的听众说明一下，这指的是捆绑、支配、臣服、施虐受虐，也就是性实践，你在书中对此进行了长篇大论的探讨，你深入探讨了几种可能的解释，来回答为什么我们中的许多人似乎真的很喜欢做那些带给我们身体或情感痛苦的事情。在你看来，这背后的根本原因是什么？
Yeah, I should also say I'm kind of a vanilla person myself. And so I end up talking about experiences that I end up reading about, but not necessarily participating. Just to clear that one up. I think there are many ways in which suffering can give us pleasure. And a lot of my book is review of the work of other psychologists and neuroscientists and philosophers. One way is contrast. So we tend to judge and experience things not as absolute, but relative to what's gone before, relative to what we're expecting. And sometimes I think the pleasure of something can be in terms, can we establish suffering and difficulty in pain
是的，我也应该说，我自己其实也是个很传统的人。所以我最终谈论的是那些我阅读过但并不一定亲身参与的经历。澄清一下这一点。我认为痛苦可以给我们带来快乐的方式有很多。我的书很大一部分是对其他心理学家、神经科学家和哲学家工作的回顾。其中一种方式是对比。所以我们倾向于判断和体验事物，不是绝对的，而是相对于之前发生的事情，相对于我们的预期。有时我认为某些事情的快乐可以用以下方式来解释，我们是否能够建立痛苦、困难和痛苦，
because it feels so good when we stop. The bite of hot curry is painful in and of itself, but then you drink this cool beer and you feel really good. You go for a hard run, then you stop. He feels great. The bath is hot, but then it's just right. And so some of its contrast, some of it's the pleasure of mastery. You know, you put yourself in a difficult situation,
因为当我们停下来时感觉太棒了。热咖喱的辛辣本身是痛苦的，但接着你喝了这杯冰啤酒，你感觉真的很好。你去进行了一场艰苦的跑步，然后你停下来。感觉好极了。洗澡水很热，但随后就刚刚好。所以其中一些是对比，其中一些是掌握的快乐。你知道，你让自己陷入困境，
you know, running is a good example or something scary, and you cope with it and you feel satisfaction that you're coping with it. some of it just to go to BDSM because Roy Balmeister's theory BDSM is that it's an escape from the self and you might think that's what you know it's kind of a weird voodooy way of talking about it but but sometimes our self-consciousness our self-thoughts are unpleasant and good sharp sudden pain is often a way of clearing our head and so so those are sort of three stories and there are others as to why we might get pleasure of the pain so you also talk in the book about the the difficult things we do that we don't necessarily enjoy, some of which you've just articulated,
你知道，跑步就是一个很好的例子，或者经历可怕的事情，你应对了它，你会为自己能够应对它而感到满足。其中一些——说到BDSM，因为罗伊·鲍迈斯特（Roy Baumeister）关于BDSM的理论是，它是对自我的逃避，你可能会认为这你知道这是一种奇怪的、带有神秘色彩的说法，但有时我们的自我意识、关于自我的想法是不愉快的，而强烈、突然的锐痛通常是清醒头脑的一种方式，所以这些是关于为什么我们能从痛苦中获得快乐的三种说法，还有其他原因。所以你在书中也谈到了我们所做的那些并不一定享受的困难事情，其中一些你刚才已经阐述过了，
why do we find meaning in pushing ourselves to climb mountains and run marathons? And is actual suffering an essential part of that? Is there no meaning if there's no suffering? I think there's no meaning if there's no suffering, or at least if there's not a chance of suffering. I think our common sense notion of a meaningful activity is one that that has challenges and difficulties and struggling. It's very difficult to, I think, impossible things are saying, wow, this is a very meaningful thing I do, and it's totally easy. This is why, you know, sitting on a sofa watching Netflix isn't meaningful, but climbing a mountain might be. It's why, you know, a nice nap isn't meaningful, but having children might be.
为什么我们在逼迫自己攀登高山和跑马拉松的过程中找到了意义？真正的痛苦是其中的一个必不可少的组成部分吗？如果没有痛苦，就没有意义吗？我认为如果没有痛苦，或者至少如果没有痛苦的可能性，就没有意义。我认为我们对有意义活动的常识性概念是那种充满挑战、困难和挣扎的活动。我认为，要去说“哇，我在做一件非常有意义的事情，而且它完全轻而易举”，这非常困难，甚至是不可可能的。这就是为什么，你知道，坐在沙发上看Netflix是没有意义的，但爬山却可能有。这就是为什么，你知道，睡个好觉是没有意义的，但抚养孩子却可能有。
And it's an important distinction because when we engage in certain activities, I don't think we're actually seeking out suffering and pain. I say, I want to run a triathlon. They're running a marathon, say. And when I want to run it, I'm actually hoping to have a great experience. I'm not seeking out blisters and sprained ankles and struggle and disappointment. But without the possibility of pain and difficulty, there'd be no enjoyment, no deeper satisfaction. So, yeah, I think the some extent suffering and meaning are inextricably linked.
这是一个重要的区别，因为当我们参与某些活动时，我认为我们其实并不是在主动寻找痛苦。我说，我想参加铁人三项。他们说的是跑马拉松。而当我想要去跑时，我其实是希望有一段美好的经历。我并不是在寻找水泡、扭伤的脚踝、挣扎和失望。但如果没有痛苦和困难的可能性，就不会有快乐，也不会有更深的满足感。所以，是的，我认为在某种程度上，痛苦和意义是密不可分的。
Do people who have more meaning in their lives than usually have less day-to-day happiness, or can you kind of maximize both? You can maximize both. There's been some very nice research. And again, there's work by Baummeister and Kathleen Voss and their colleagues where they ask people about how happy your life is and how meaningful your life is and ask all sorts of questions. And one finding is that these things are not essentially in opposition. In fact, they're correlated.
生活中更有意义的人，通常日常幸福感会更少吗？还是说你可以将两者同时最大化？你可以将两者同时最大化。有一些非常好的研究。同样，鲍迈斯特、凯瑟琳·沃斯（Kathleen Vohs）和他们的同事也做过这样的工作，他们询问人们的生活有多幸福、有多有意义，并提出了各种各样的问题。其中一个发现是，这些事情本质上并不是对立的。事实上，它们是呈正相关关系的。
Somebody who says their life is happy is more likely than not to say their life is meaningful and vice versa. But at the same time, they're not one and the same. So they looked at people who say they have happy lives versus very happy lives versus very meaningful lives. And the people who say they have very meaningful lives report more anxiety, more struggle, more difficulty, more stress, they had to have more children. They might be happy, but they're struggling.
说自己生活幸福的人，更有可能说自己的生活是有意义的，反之亦然。但与此同时，它们又不是同一回事。因此，他们研究了那些自称生活幸福的人与生活非常幸福的人，以及生活非常富有意义的人。那些自称生活非常富有意义的人报告了更多的焦虑、更多的挣扎、更多的困难、更多的压力，他们往往有更多的孩子。他们可能会感到幸福，但他们也在挣扎。
Well, there are people who claim to have very happy lives whose lives contain and comparative relatively less struggle and difficulty. Your book also talks about the connection between suffering and morality, the idea that if you do something that in any way benefits yourself, people won't see it as altruistic or good. So where does this idea come from that doing good has to somehow hurt, has to be painful? I don't know where it comes from, but I know it's true. There's some nice research by colleagues and friends of mine, Daley and Kane and George Newman,
嗯，有些人声称自己过着非常幸福的生活，他们的生活包含着相对较少的挣扎和困难。你的书还谈到了痛苦与道德之间的联系，这种观点认为，如果你做了任何对你自己有一点好处的事情，人们就不会认为这是利他或善良的。那么，这种“行善必须在某种程度上带来痛苦、必须是痛苦的”观点是从哪里来的呢？我不知道它从哪里来，但我知道它是真的。我的同事和朋友戴利（Daley）、凯恩（Cane）以及乔治·纽曼（George Newman）做了一些很棒的研究，
who were at Yale with me, who they have discovered, talk about what they call tainted altruism. And it turns out that, and there's real world examples, let's be do this in the lab, that people who do good but kind of enjoy it and gain something from it, we don't think there is good people. We like our people who do good to suffer. And this shows up, this shows up, you know, it shows up in the charities we do. So, so you ever ask yourself, why are there like fun runs? Why do people pour ice water over your heads to raise money for treatments for ALS?
他们曾和我一起在耶鲁工作，他们发现了并谈论了他们所谓的“被玷污的利他主义”。事实证明，并且有现实世界的例子，让我们在实验室里做一下这个实验，那些行善但又有点享受其中并从中获得某些好处的人，我们不认为他们是好人。我们喜欢我们行善的人受苦。这表现出来，这表现出来，你知道，它表现在我们所做的慈善事业中。所以，你有没有问过自己，为什么会有“趣味路跑”这种东西？为什么人们要把冰水倒在头上，来为渐冻症（ALS）的治疗筹款？
Why don't they have fun massages or why don't they eat chocolate cuisants to raise money for ALS? Well, the answer is for whatever quirk of our heads, we relate suffering and morality. So, you know, if all of a sudden I want to raise money for a good cause, they're got to be suffering in it. It rings true in so many ways, and it's really hard to put my finger on why. I mean, years ago, I did an AIDS ride, for example, you know, 300 miles over three days. And, I mean, that was a killer. And, yeah, I raised money and I also had a great sense of achievement. You know, if I had just walked for three days, I probably would have been painful, too, but riding a bike for three days, man, that was a killer.
为什么他们不搞有趣的按摩，或者为什么他们不通过吃巧克力牛角面包来为ALS筹款呢？好吧，答案是，由于我们大脑的某种怪癖，我们将痛苦与道德联系在了一起。所以，你知道，如果我突然想为一个好事业筹款，其中必须包含痛苦。这在很多方面都说得通，而且我真的很难指出原因。例如，多年前我参加了一场抗击艾滋病的骑行活动，你知道，三天骑行300英里。我的意思是，那简直要命。是的，我筹到了钱，我也有一种巨大的成就感。你知道，如果我只是步行三天，可能也会很痛苦，但是骑自行车三天，天哪，那真要命。
I hear you say this. and I think you're a great person. And if you told me, to raise money for this worthy cause, instead you participated, you lay in your sofa and you watched HBO and bank beer, I think, okay, it's kind of something, but no, you're not as good a person.
我听你这么说，我觉得你是个好人。如果你告诉我，为了这个崇高事业筹款，你反而躺在沙发上看着HBO喝着啤酒，我想，好吧，这也算做了一点什么，但不，你不是一个那么好的人。
You thought this was your run club era. Turns out it was more of a thinking about run club era. The good news? Someone's marathon training is about to start. Sell your workout gear on Deepop. Just snap a few photos, and we'll take care of the rest. They get their race day fit, and you get a payout for trying. Someone on Deepop wants what you've got.
你以为这是你的跑步俱乐部时代。结果发现它更像是一个“考虑跑步俱乐部”的好消息？某人的马拉松训练即将开始。在Depop上出售你的运动装备。只需拍几张照片，剩下的交给我们。他们获得了比赛日的装备，而你因尝试而获得了一笔收入。Depop上有人想要你拥有的东西。
Start selling now. Deepop, where Taste recognizes Taste. I wrote a little song to remind you, Choice Hotels, get you more of the experiences you value. The can be a hotel's got it all. A rooftop ball, have a ball. Cocktails. up here feel just right.
立即开始销售。Depop，在这里品味遇到品味。我写了一首小歌来提醒你，精选酒店（Choice Hotels）让你获得更多你所珍视的体验。这家酒店应有尽有。屋顶派对，尽情狂欢。鸡尾酒。这里的氛围恰到好处。
Is Cambri your home made? Bring a date, your teen, or even your mom. Book direct at choiceotails.com. See you on the roof. Well, let's talk for a minute about the difference between chosen and unchosen suffering.
坎布里亚（Cambria）是你的家外之家吗？带上约会对象、你的青少年孩子，甚至你的妈妈。请直接在choiceotels.com上预订。我们在屋顶见。好吧，让我们花一分钟来谈谈自愿痛苦和非自愿痛苦之间的区别。
Terrible things happen to people all the time. People get ill. They're victims of violence. Their loved ones die. And there's a theory that's become popular called post-traumatic growth. which says that people who endure trauma see some positive growth afterward, that they somehow become kinder or wiser.
可怕的事情随时都在发生。人们生病了。他们成为暴力的受害者。他们爱的人离世了。有一个变得很流行的理论叫做“创伤后成长”，该理论认为，经历创伤的人会在之后看到一些积极的成长，他们不知何故变得更加善良或更加睿智。
And you argue against that. So can you talk about that a little bit? I do. And it's an absolutely critical distinction. Right before my book came out, I had a summary of it published in the Wall Street Journal. And you get emails. And right away, I got an email. And a person said, you are such an idiot.
而你反对这种说法。所以你能稍微谈谈这个吗？我确实反对。这是一个绝对至关重要的区别。就在我的书出版前不久，我在《华尔街日报》上发表了一篇摘要。然后你就会收到电子邮件。我立刻收到了一封邮件。那个人说，你真是个白痴。
You are pro-suffering. And she said, I live with chronic pain. how can you be so cruel to say that my life is benefiting for my suffering? And I wrote to it right back and said, you know, I know there's a distinction there which I actually make, which is chosen suffering, I think, has a lot of benefits and there's a lot of value. Unchosen suffering is a very mixed bag. Unchosen suffering. And, you know, we're living in a pandemic.
你是在支持痛苦。她说，我带着慢性疼痛生活，你怎么能这么残忍地说我的生活从痛苦中受益了？我立刻回信告诉她，你知道，那里其实存在一个我确实做出了区分的区别，那就是自愿的痛苦，我认为有很多好处，也有很多价值。非自愿的痛苦则是一个非常混杂的包袱。非自愿的痛苦。而且，你知道，我们生活在大流行中。
There's plenty of unchosen suffering around. But it's by no means clear unchosen suffering has to benefit of chosen suffering. Now, when I say this, I bump up again. people and, you know, some really respected scholars, psychologists, psychiatrists, who say, no, very often unchosen suffering, the death of a child, a severe serious illness, something your house burns down, you lose your job, has benefits. They call it post-traumatic growth to distinguish it from post-traumatic stress disorder. But I got to say I'm a skeptic. I review a literature in my book saying that, although people often think that bad experiences
周围有大量的非自愿痛苦。但绝不清楚非自愿痛苦是否具有自愿痛苦的好处。现在，当我这么说时，我又遇到了反对意见。人们，你知道，一些非常受尊敬的学者、心理学家、精神病学家说，不，很多时候非自愿的痛苦——一个孩子的死、严重的重病、你的房子烧毁了、你失业了——都有好处。他们称之为“创伤后成长”，以将其与“创伤后应激障碍”区分开来。但我必须说我是一个怀疑论者。我在书里回顾了相关文献，指出尽管人们经常认为糟糕的经历，
make them stronger, and I'd be crazy to deny that in some cases a bad experience could make you stronger. People are complicated. There's no regular rule that bad things are good for you. The good news is we seem to be very resilient. Bad things don't hurt us as much as we often think they will, but bad experiences are actually, for the most part, not good for us. And to say otherwise is wishful thinking. And I also think it's, I think it's something important to get right. Because if you're wrong and you tell people, oh, my gosh, your kid died, well, I'm sure there's a lot of growth's going to happen. It sets up unrealistic and unfair expectations. I think a better thing to say is that's horrible.
会让他们变得更坚强——如果我否认在某些情况下糟糕的经历确实能让你变得更坚强，那我就是疯了。人类是很复杂的。并没有什么常规的规则说坏事对你有好处。好消息是，我们似乎非常有韧性。坏事对我们的伤害并没有我们想象的那么大，但糟糕的经历实际上在大多数情况下对我们是没有好处的。说反话是一厢情愿的想法。我也认为，把这一点弄明白非常重要。因为如果你错了，你告诉人们，哦，天哪，你的孩子死了，嗯，我确信会有很多成长发生。这会设定不切实际且不公平的期望。我认为更好的说法是，这太可怕了。
And I hope you, it's going to take you time, but I hope you recover. And isn't it a case of people sort of rationalizing to themselves in a sense? Because there's no way to turn the clock back and make it not happen. You can't compare my life went this way or my life went that way. it's going the way that it's going. And so you've got to find some meaning from a terrible thing that happened to you. That's right. And in some way, you could be viewed as what psychologists call cognitive dissonance,
我希望你，这需要时间，但我希望你能恢复。这难道不是人们在某种意义上进行自我合理化的一个例子吗？因为没有办法让时间倒流并让它不发生。你没法对比“我的生活走这条路”还是“我的生活走那条路”。事情正朝着它现在的方式发展。所以你必须从发生在你身上的可怕事情中找到某种意义。没错。从某种程度上说，这可以被视为心理学家所说的认知失调，
or Dan Gilbert calls the psychological immune system, which is a healthy mind when faced with some bad news, tries to make a good news, tries to say, well, I'm sure there's an upside to this. And I'm not sure it's bad to sort of come in with that attitude, but I think this belief is largely a cognitive illusion. evolution, that in fact bad things often don't have upsides. Be nice if it were so, but it's for the most part not true.
或者丹·吉尔伯特（Dan Gilbert）所说的心理免疫系统，也就是说一个健康的头脑在面对一些坏消息时，会努力寻找好消息，试图说服自己，嗯，我确信这背后有积极的一面。我不确定带着这种态度切入是否是件坏事，但我认为这种信念在很大程度上是一种认知错觉。演化，事实上坏事往往没有积极的一面。如果能那样就好了，但大多数情况下并非如此。
It's been a lot of discussion recently about how politically polarized the United States is right now and even in the face of a traumatic event like the COVID-19 pandemic. How unusual is this when communities experience suffering together like in a pandemic or a natural disaster? Does it usually bring people together or does it usually tear them apart? It depends on the crisis. So a lot of people, include some friends of mine when this pandemic began, said, well, here's the silver lining, which is there's an excellent historical record that when bad things
最近有很多关于美国目前的政治极化程度有多高，甚至在面对诸如COVID-19大流行这样的创伤性事件时也是如此的讨论。当社区共同经历痛苦（比如在大流行或自然灾害中）时，这种情况有多罕见？它通常会将人们聚在一起，还是通常会将他们撕裂？这取决于危机。所以很多人，包括这场大流行开始时我的一些朋友说，好吧，这里有一线生机，那就是有极好的历史记录表明，当坏事
happen to people, it brings them together. It fosters a sense of community, of love, of meaning. People give examples of tsunamis and earthquakes, the 9-11 attacks. the bombing of London during the Blitz in World War II. And Rebecca Solnett has a wonderful book called A Paradise Built in Hell, where she talks about how these things give meaning to community. And she said, in some way, here's this overlining of a pandemic. We're all going to come together.
降临到人们身上时，它会将他们凝聚在一起。它培养了一种社区感、爱和意义。人们举出了海啸和地震、9-11袭击的例子。二战期间闪电战期间对伦敦的轰炸。丽贝卡·索尔尼特（Rebecca Solnit）有一本精彩的书叫《人间天堂》（A Paradise Built in Hell），她在书中讲述了这些事情如何赋予社区以意义。她说，在某种程度上，这就是大流行的有一线生机。我们都将走到一起。
But the problem is this doesn't work for pandemics. Stories of the Spanish flu suggest that during that time, people just got mean. They didn't form communities. They were increasingly antagonistic towards immigrants. And there was not much positive because what happens in this sort of crisis is it isolates us. What we are doing, we are not dealing with COVID by gathering the streets and celebrating or keeping a stiff upper lip as, you know, the bombs fall from above.
但问题是这不适用于大流行。关于西班牙流感的历史表明，在那段时期，人们变得很刻薄。他们没有形成社区。他们对移民越来越具有敌意。并没有太多积极的东西，因为这种危机发生时，它会孤立我们。我们在做什么，我们不是通过走上街头庆祝来应对新冠疫情，也不是像炸弹从天而降时那样咬紧牙关保持坚强。
We're all sitting at home ordering from Uber Eats and staying by ourselves. It's isolating. I wish it weren't so. But not all crises lead to this sort of solidarity and growth. one certainly has not. And this one, and this is not something I study, but just an observation seems to have fueled political polarization rather than dampened it. Let's switch gears for a minute here. Your previous book was called Against Empathy, and in it you made a counterintuitive argument that empathy is often a bad thing, that
我们都坐在家里用Uber Eats点外卖，独自呆着。这是一种孤立。我希望事实并非如此。但并非所有危机都会导致这种团结和成长。这一次肯定没有。而且这一次——这不是我研究的课题，但仅仅是一个观察结果——似乎加剧了政治极化，而不是减弱了它。让我们在这里转换一下话题。你以前的一本书叫《反对同理心》，在书中你提出了一个违反直觉的论点，即同理心往往是一件坏事，
it's a bad basis for making moral decisions. Can you talk a little bit about that idea? A friend of mine tells me that my books are sort of everything that looks good is bad and everything that looks bad is good. But I stand by my anti-empathy argument. I have to begin with the most boring of all ways, which is by defining my terms, because some people use the term empathy to mean understanding other people, and I'm in favor of that. And some people use empathy simply to mean being good, being kind, being loving, being a mention, and I'm in favor of that. But there's a sense which a lot of psychologists use it and a lot of people use it, which is feeling the pain of another person. And a lot of people say, well, to be empath, to be a good moral person, you have to feel the world as others feel it. And I argue that this is a horrible moral guide.
它是做出道德决策的糟糕基础。你能稍微谈谈这个想法吗？我的一个朋友告诉我，我的书基本上是“所有看起来好的东西都是坏的，所有看起来坏的东西都是好的”。但我坚持我的“反同理心”论点。我必须以最乏味的方式开始，也就是定义我的术语，因为有些人用“同理心”这个词来表示理解他人，我是赞成这一点的。有些人用“同理心”简单地表示善良、仁慈、充满爱心、成为一个好人，我是赞成这一点的。但有很多心理学家和很多人使用这个词时，指的是感同身受另一个人的痛苦。很多人会说，为了有同理心，为了成为一个有道德的好人，你必须像其他人一样感受这个世界。而我争辩说，这是一个糟糕的道德指南。
And I have many arguments, but the main argument I give is that there's a million studies plus common sense that tell you that it's most natural to feel empathy for somebody you look like. or someone's a member of your tribe or speaks the same language. I can naturally feel tremendous empathy for other professors in my department, for my wife and my kids, for other my neighbors. But we don't naturally feel empathy for people who are afraid of or who don't look like us or speak a different language or live in another country. And fortunately, I argue, we have other moral resources. We have compassion, we have love, and we have rationality.
我有很多论点，但我提出的主要论点是，有数百万项研究加上常识告诉你，对和你长相相似的人产生同理心是最自然的。或者某人是你的部落成员，或者说相同的语言。我可以自然地对我们部门的其他教授、对我的妻子和孩子、对我的邻居产生巨大的同理心。但我们不会自然地对那些我们害怕的人、长相与我们不同的人、说不同语言的人或生活在另一个国家的人产生同理心。幸运的是，我认为，我们还有其他的道德资源。我们有同情心，我们有爱，我们有理性。
And even though I do not feel empathy for somebody in a faraway land or for someone whose political views differ from my own, I can understand their people just like me and I could extend my natural compassion towards them. So given that you seem to have an affinity for making counterintuitive arguments, where do you go next? What are you looking at now? I'm currently working on a book, which is introduction psychology, but not a textbook, not a book for declination. classroom, but a popular book that somebody just interested in psychology could pick it up. And the subtitle right now is an opinionated terror of the mind. So I'm sure there's going to be parts where I'm going to tell you what seems to be good as bad, vice versa. But I don't expect this one to be particularly controversial, I hope not.
尽管我对远方土地上的人或政治观点与我不同的人没有同理心，但我能理解他们和我一样都是人，我可以将我自然的同情心延伸到他们身上。鉴于你似乎对提出违反直觉的论点情有独钟，你接下来打算去哪儿？你现在在关注什么？我目前正在写一本书，这是一本关于心理学导论的书，但不是教科书，不是为教室写的书，而是一本对心理学感兴趣的人都可以拿起来读的大众读物。目前的副标题是“一个任性的心灵解析”。所以我确信会有一些部分，我要告诉你哪些看起来好的其实是坏的，反之亦然。但我预计这本书不会特别具有争议性，我希望不会。
I would think that you'd have quite an audience for it. I mean, what we find at the American Psychological Association is a great deal of interest on the part of the general public in understanding more. about psychology and how it works, what it does. Well, as my grandmother would say from your mouth, the God's ear. Well, thank you so much for joining us today. Dr. Bloom, this has been really interesting, and I wish you great good luck with your upcoming book.
我想你会有相当多的受众。我的意思是，我们在美国心理学会发现，广大公众对更多地了解心理学及其运作方式、作用表现出极大的兴趣。正如我奶奶会说的那样，借你吉言。好吧，非常感谢今天能加入我们的节目。布鲁姆博士，这真的非常有趣，祝你即将出版的书取得巨大成功。
Thank you. Thank you so much, and this has been a wonderful conversation. I really appreciate you having me here. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speaking of psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, Spotify, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's speaking of psychology, all one word, at APA.org.
谢谢。非常感谢，这是一次精彩的对话。非常感谢你邀请我来这里。你可以在我们的网站speaking of psychology.org上，或者在Apple、Stitcher、Spotify或任何你获取播客的地方找到《说心理学》以往的节目。如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以给我们发电子邮件：speaking of psychology at APA.org。也就是speaking of psychology，全部连在一起，@APA.org。
Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condihan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《说心理学》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的音频剪辑是克里斯·康迪汉（Chris Condihan）。谢谢收听。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。